Daniel X started coding at age 14. by
the age of 23 he had sold an advertising
business for millions of dollars at that
point he retired he lived in a luxury
apartment and he also drove a Ferrari
but Daniel Eck realized something that
many others have realized along the way
money didn't make him happy and so
Daniel Eck did what any founder would do
he jumped back in the game and he built
Spotify a multi-billion Dollar business
that has taken the music podcast and
audio industry by storm the big lesson
from Daniel X life is that no matter how
much success you have early on you have
to keep building that's why human nature
intrinsically is all about